If you're new to this channel one of the things we like to do around here is do creative
Experiments everything from build a net gun to build a potato camera to heck we even made a seven-foot electric skateboard
No one on the Internet has built a full-sized, fully functional guillotine. We knew we had to do it
Not only did this seem like a creative challenge, but also one of historical significance and in addition on Friday evenings
We like to go down and get a couple of beers
We figured if this guillotine can make enough money to earn 50 bucks a month
It'll be able to pay for those beers
I need to deconstruct part of the studio in order for me to get this guillotine build done today. So
Like anything good work takes time and six months later. Here. We are
all that's left to build is the blade and slide in I
Told you guys we weren't as close as I thought we were and it turns out that that was true
I am NOT a carpenter. I'm a fan of carpentry
I
Didn't really know the function of a router and all you commenters
Thank you for for slapping yourself on the heads and typing in router Jake router
I got a router. I went back and bought two more of these four by fours, and I redid this whole mass. Oh man, all that
Work, but basically I rerouted this which allowed me to then put in these aluminum triangles. It's gonna be a slide
It's gonna have a detachable blade on it
My ultimate goal here is to create a prototype
That will slide all the way down the guillotine without falling out or being janky or anything. once we have a functioning slide
I'll feel confident enough to take this whole design to a machinist so they can make something out of metal
I don't want to do any experimentation with machinists because that could get expensive really fast. This is gonna be loud when it hits I
I dedicate this guillotine Big Chunga's
We have to smash this head that's all I give the people what they want
Building to baby the palace. Well, the rest of the people of France are starving.  Finish it Chet , Finish it!
It's easy to understand. How carried away the French got when we're already getting super excited like
Now that we know that it works we're gonna go to the machinist we're gonna have him make a
functioning blade and slide based upon this prototype
All right, we made it. We're here at Eric machinery custom machine work since 1924. We're gonna go in see about getting this blade made
Without all sorts of things now get in
I've got some dimensions for it. We can put up Slaven games. I do want the plate to be pretty big
So I think 1/2 an inch
You gotta love places like this with all the different machines
They have in here the ability to just go I can make anything I want. Yeah, my dad had this exact table saw
So while the blades being manufactured we're gonna paint the whole guillotine white might change later, but for now
This is gonna be a great base coat and give us a starting point
Today is a very special day in the life of this guillotine just as with a newborn child. The baptism is a
Beautiful moment in its life today is the day that we get a real Frenchman to hopefully give his blessings on our guillotine
They say that all guillotines must be approved by an official Frenchman. How do you say it again?
There's been a lot of debate
how do we say the word guillotine guillotines guilty guillotine guillotines guillotine doesn't really matter how I say it
Everyone in the comments everyone in the studio. There is no debate. It's pronounced dial tine scutum
Guess what everybody we're gonna settle this once and for all to figure out how you say the name of this here device after that
I don't want to see a single comment. I've got $5.00 American on guillotine. Well, I'll bet you five that. It's guillotine
On it. I bet five dollars has pronounced Galton. All right
We're making a whole channel I was gonna say it
I'm helping
Henry if you would, please come forward and and slowly with confidence of all your ancestors place your hands on the guillotine
Oh my god, it's beauty. That's the word guillotine
Just screaming I was obviously the closest so you guys actually owe me I don't believe any of this
A guillotine is not a real guillotine a Frenchman's blessing. I
*Pompous gibberish* ...listen that you can cut properly among yours and theirs. Amen.
It's very, very, very stupid to have done that, I do not know why they did that. I ... It even costs money, it's expensive!
Muy bien !
Now that that guillotine has been blessed I wanted to bless you guys with a little secret people ask us all the time
What kind of music we use in our videos and including this video and this last scene?
You just saw we get our music from today's sponsor epidemic if you post videos online
Epidemic is a great way to get a bunch of music for those videos they have over
30,000 tracks that are updated weekly
They also have editorial selections you guys done a time to go through
30,000 tracks now with a creator subscription to epidemic you are white list it across YouTube Facebook Twitter Instagram
and if you choose to end your subscription at any time all the content that you made during that period on those platforms is
100% good to go. It'll never be touched all the tracks that you get from epidemic come with stems
So if you just like the baseline
Or you just want the violin from one piece?
You can pull the stems put it in your video and adjust it and make it as you see fit
It create a subscription is only 15 bucks a month
What the music you heard in the last scene the music you're hearing right now. It can be yours
Just click the link in the description two months free. That's it
Now you guys know you don't need to ask us any more in the comments
All right, I'm gonna get back to it
It's just steel sheet metal coldly machined and sharpened and it's the most magnificent thing
I've seen since the birth of my children. The problem is that I thought it was gonna be 30 pounds
It's 50 the slight building flaw that was inherent to the four by fours that I was using is now
Causing a problem. This masked 100% straight. This one has a slight warp to it
See it blows out slightly. That means that even though at the top and bottom
It's 17 and 3/8 inches in the center
it's just slightly wider and a slight variation when you're doing with a sharpened piece of steel that can chop a horse's head off is
Way too dangerous. I need to make this thing safe before we use it. I can't wait to taste that beard, dude
I can't believe we did all this for beer the first
day that we
Go out and use an adsense check to buy a bunch of beer for this is gonna be that's just gonna be such a good
Day Suns gonna taste so good, huh? Oh
You got it you just touch them in you just touch them this has so much force
It's like a train but it's just gonna plow through stuff. This is it
on wheels
In order to fix the bowing problem
I used two two by fours with carriage bolts to bring the entire mast slightly closer together
This will prevent the blade from having any chance of sliding out as for the stopping mechanism
I got this rubber right here
you guys can go ahead and please actually leave me comments in terms of what you think would be a better stopping mechanism and I
Understand that it's not the best thing to
Stop all the force of the blade and slide by where the blade impacts
But I want to try this first just super super hard. Rubber is like a giant
200-pound slab of rubber. Oh my gosh. Where did you get that?
Where did you get that Oh mother mother Hummer. Oh my god
Oh my god. I think I just threw up my back. Just lifting up
I'm just gonna cut a chunk out of it and just put it on the bottom one hour. Later
Dude look at this. I don't know how it was even cut in the first place
I have no idea where this material like came from Mars
How am I supposed to cut all the way down this I need this to work?
This was my what this was my solution that this has to work
desperate times call for desperate measures
How to cut rubber box cutter entire cutter hammer knife
There's no way to do this
This is the worst, how do we come to this? How did we get here?
Can't I can't do this
This is the perfect time to do it if we can make 50 bucks a month
For the beer for the beer for the beer the beer the beer the beer
This is one of the most unpleasant things I've ever cut through and I've cut through a lot of unpleasant things crabs at Disneyland
LA traffic
Ready yep ready
Ha I knew the rubber I look at it barely made a dent knew the rubber was a good idea
I think we can go we can go big
Like many need a couple guys on the team since we don't have a wench I
Need everyone paying attention for this this is like firing off a firearms and I have no idea what's gonna happen
It is going to completely explode we're gonna find pieces up in the kitchen. All right guys
I
Know I know find out ready. Oh
That's perfect. Yeah, it doesn't bounce much you know, how your camera shook there
Ya know what that means the concrete ground flexed a little bit
We felt that next door. Really. Yeah
Now that it's like functioning and I and I have it all working now
We can like add a bench in the front. We can add a winch on the side. I think we're ready to the job
I think we're ready to start this channel
Three-two-one. Oh you thought it was gonna chop you thought we were gonna put the guillotine videos on this channel
No, there's a channel called youtube.com slash guillotine channel subscribe for pure unadulterated guillotine related content
Hello and welcome back to the guillotine channel your source for family-friendly guillotine content
Don't you hate how you used to have to watch a whole documentary on the French Revolutions?
This is just to see one good guillotine chop